also my nephew had hand foot and mouth  disease now why is it that it's just the  hand the foot and the mouth it's because  the hands and the feet are going in the  mouth are we talking like Meg you looked  it up is it a virus  and it's just one of those things that  just goes away on its own oh it's like a  chickenpox technique yeah the the  chickenpox virus lives with you forever  yes  party of like viruses where they're all  hanging out you know what I mean it's  like are you uh you repeat her are you  like a one-time guy like me I go to the  hand I go to the foot I go to the mouth  you what it kind of show up in the hand  as you open the foot I show up in the  mouth the kid feels terrible uh I also  go to adults but and herpes is like I go  to the mouth I go oh [ __ ]  big deal hey Kobe what's up new guy I  think she's so [ __ ] cool